foreign
College grads have got a over inflated
View
of what they could make and should make
that is that a fair way of saying that
that's a very fair way and you get some
more data on your hands yeah this is
pretty wild as hiring demands increases
from cnbc.com the average starting
salary for the class of 2022 is
projected to be more than fifty thousand
okay checks out however current college
students expect to earn twice that a
hundred and three thousand eight hundred
and eighty dollars in their first job
according to one report yeah that's a
problem it is a problem it's not
realistic the Market's not there the
question is and I've not seen any of
these articles that that offer an
opinion as to why I think I have an
opinion but what say you
um I interviewed a bunch of high
schoolers and when I talked to them they
all were like well yeah I'm gonna make a
I'm gonna make six figures when I
graduate and I was like what makes you
think that right there's no reality it's
just kind of this wet finger in the air
and I think I deserve and the the way
things are going with the economy you
need to make a hundred thousand so I'm
just gonna go make a hundred thousand
yeah and so here's what's dangerous
about this if you were one of these
young people and you're listening and
watch this listen we're not bashing you
right now I don't want you to hear
here's Ken and George the old cranky
guys like the Muppets those two Muppet
guys that sat in the top you know the
balcony
um yeah those guys here's the deal
here's here's why I want you to really
do your homework on what the jobs are
offering what you're going to look at
and George just gave you the number
because when you have unrealistic
expectations
George you are going to have unmet
and so that starts you off right out of
the gate with a certain amount of
resentment in cynicism and frustration
and everything that comes with that and
so this is interesting so the number is
they're expected to start at you said it
was 55 well they're expected to start at
over just over 50. oh just over fifty
thousand I bet their expectations are
that they're gonna be yeah 103 plus and
it says 10 years into the careers
students anticipate making more than two
hundred thousand dollars yeah well so
they are way overestimating their
starting salaries one report says by 88
and so they need to understand what
degree am I after what are the jobs on
the other side of that degree and what
do those jobs pay in my area with my
experience all right so now those are
the steps to take yeah I agree and and
so we want to know okay what does it
look like they've got to know the
industry and then more importantly young
people listen go hang out with women and
men who are winning in your industry
and then say hey if I'm going to make or
if I if I want to make two hundred
thousand dollars in 10 years what would
need to be true
like let's just get some real coffee and
some real knowledge and so that you have
an idea what what you need to expect now
I want to flip this for a second in my
hands here I've got an article uh I like
that I bring my paper I bring my own
sound effects and uh this is an op-ed uh
uh on Fox news but listen to this
the world is changing as it relates to
college degree and professional success
now George you know this I talk about
this all the time Ad nauseam next to
your desk and I it makes me nauseous
yeah it does I talk about it too much
I'm very passionate about it but the
level the leveling of the playing field
is here and it's good for people who
don't have a degree now there are people
that are listening and watching to us
right now
that they feel stuck because they I did
they don't want to go get another degree
because either they want to Pivot and
they feel like they need that
qualification or they don't want to stay
in the same field that they're in with
the degree they have and they think oh I
need a degree maybe not but here's how
it's changing the headline here is
employers are wising up
between 2007 and 2019 George the sheriff
job postings requiring a four-year
degree Rose more than 60 percent wow
they called it degree inflation
so it was a little bit of a monkey sea
monkey do everybody's doing it we don't
want to be the ones that aren't doing it
and we feel like well we're going to get
the Riff Raff we filtered the Riff Raff
out because if you don't have a degree
you're not as good as somebody else and
I'm being honest I'm not trying to play
on some populism here well it's kind of
like the credit score it's just an easy
way to go we're too lazy to look into
their finances the credit score tells us
it's a great experience great goal so
that the degree in the credit score have
become somewhat of the same thing it's a
measuring tool but does it actually
matter we know it doesn't you got you
bought a house without a credit score
that's right and we teach this all the
time all right so real quick though
here's what's interesting in 1990 this
is the same time that that we we begin
to see uh a real difference in prime age
workers who are earning between sixty
and eighty thousand dollars a year all
right so 38 earning between 60 and 80
000 per year a year had a bachelor's
degree
okay today the proportion is 52 percent
so it's about degree degree degree but
listen to this four in ten recent
College grads working jobs that have not
traditionally required a college degree
and in that case the college graduates
in non-college degree requirement jobs
are earning more than ten thousand
dollars Less in other words the way they
write that's confusing sure
if you have a college degree you're
making over ten thousand dollars less
than your Compadres who have no degree
wow wow so all that to say two questions
that I teach
for our new audience members if you've
never heard me say this before there's
two questions you can ask is a degree
the only way to get the job I want or is
it the best way
now you got to dig but the research is
readily available George it's not a
mystery no and the answer is no either
one here's the great news there's more
and more jobs coming online you have
state governments I didn't mention this
11 states now have removed college
degree requirements for you to get a job
in their executive branch
11 Governors said we're changing it so I
just think this is a trend it's a great
job I'm very happy about this shift and
the truth is anecdotally as we take
calls on the show the folks that have
degrees they call in they go I'm making
40 grand and I'm 100 000 in debt the
folks that don't have degrees they call
in and they go well I'm 19 and I make 80
grand as a welder and I have no debt
that's right and I go who would you
rather be yeah and guess who's not
desperate for the raise and not
struggling and anxious in their job the
guy who has no debt who's making 80
grand with no college degree yeah so I'm
just tired of this system that's pushed
all of these kids through to focus on a
degree without thinking about what's on
the other side well let's not forget
that we pushed him into this they were
told it was the right way to do it and
then they come out of school
and the debt payments are killing them
they don't feel like they're ever going
to climb out of the hole of the student
loan and then a politician comes along
and they promise that we're going to
wipe away twenty thousand dollars worth
of your loan and they hold on tight
years three years and then you find out
that some judges wearing black robes
said nope can't do it and they're left
holding the back and that stinks and so
look at look out look out at the future
look at the now and go wait a second do
I need a degree and if we look at the
Technology field alone George just the
Technology field
there are so many what I would call
technology trade schools Bethel Tech
betheltech.net tell them I sent you I
endorse them they have a nine month
program
less than fifteen thousand dollars
George wow and they're starting at 75
000. some are making a hundred thousand
coming out it's a trade school and it's
less than a quarter of the time which
means you have income coming in nine
months later potentially that's right
then let's look at the trades as you
mentioned welders electricians plumbers
Carpenters the field is wide open they
are desperate for people who could come
in and work and you and I were at a
conference recently where uh Malcolm
Gladwell on the stage at our entree
Leadership Summit said that he was
talking to a well-known professor at an
Ivy League school and he said what would
you tell your kids about their future
than his young kids he said I'd tell
them to get into trades
um that's powerful this is an ivy Laker
you know an elitist and uh if you will
for people like to make fun of the point
is is he's even saying the value's not
there yeah and so all that to say this
is we have this conversation because
George so many people make bad financial
decisions under
the guise of well I had to do it
well we've let the degree dictate what
job happens versus letting the job
dictate whether or not we even need a
degree there it is we've got to make
that change and if you want to learn
more about this we explore it in our
documentary called borrowed future it's
completely free on YouTube there's also
a podcast series I hosted around the
same topic and it will open your eyes
watch it with your kids and start the
conversation now also have a great
resource at our website
ramseysolutions.com called debt free
degree it's a great book easy read you
can go to college without the debt we
want you to